But another, more salient realization that comes to light
is the triviality of our own self-importance and self-consciousness.
To truly understand the extent to which your self-consciousness
prohibits you from engaging in opportunities
should lead everyone to take risks they otherwise wouldn't.
We're merely a blip on the time line of the universe, right?
Act accordingly.
Now the ideas that I'm presenting today were imbued upon me
through some otherwise unfortunate circumstances, granted,
but they're lying dormant in the lives of anyone who's willing to exploit them.
If we all understand that we all have unique weaknesses,
and if we're honest about what they are,
we can learn how to best take advantage of them,
whether they be mounting a curb or fear of presenting sales reports
or the inability to sufficiently manage one's finances --
looking at that guy --
(Laughter)
there lies the ability to learn, to adapt,
and even the ability to rewire one's instinctual response to challenges.
Adversity is good,
and it has the potential to make you stronger.
And, at the very least,
you can scare the hell out of kids if you look like a pirate.
Thanks.
(Applause and cheers)